[Musique]
allô allô
à la télé les journaux tout le monde en
parle ah le truc mais oui ce matin je
suis allé au pressing mais attends mais
tout le monde en parle tu sais que j'ai
eu le truc en ligne là
ça veut dire que tout le monde
en parle le résultat tout le monde en
parle
bonsoir bienvenue sur le plateau de Tout
le monde en parle vous connaissez le
principe tout le monde en parle alors
tout le monde en parle
vous connaissez kam et Olivier les voici
ça un triomphe absolu merci beaucoup en
même temps sur les figurants qu'on a
payé bien sûr
donc je trouve que c'est plutôt sympa de
votre part merci public adorée
à la télévision ça marche toujours tu
flattes le public tout de suite les gens
sont contents ça va très bien vous savez
pourquoi je vous demande toujours de
venir dans cette émission
oui parce que vous avez cette faculté de
donner du sens c'est vrai que des fois
on se gare un peu vous arrivez toujours
à ramener les choses la morale des
choses c'est vrai il faut qu'il y a une
moralité à chaque émission voilà vous
êtes formidable pour ça et moi quand je
ressors de là je suis plus intelligent
qu'avant c'est vrai grâce à vous
regarder Olivier avec nous ce soir
Pierre Botton
Bruno Masure
car il y a un invité mystère
mais avant évidemment comme il est de
tradition dans cette émission nous
allons voir le best of de la semaine
dernière ça s'appelle tout le monde en a
parlé
il faut que je vous vois les gens alors
on vous a demandé de venir et il faut
que vous me vouvoyez aussi d'accord ça
va être difficile ça a vu comme tu veux
moi je parle couramment les deux langues
il y a pas de problème
ça dépend si tu la vouvoies si tu l'as
vu toi
et le canot charie va deux jours de
l'arrivée
donc la première traversée le bateau
chavir à deux jours de l'arrivée
je sortais je me mets que tu as crié
pour un petit peu évacuer toute cette
peur et toutes ces souffrances
quotidienne des
requins qui ont des trompettes
c'est les requins de Hollywood requin
trompette
de loin histoire terrible avec ce cargo
qui a voulu violet là
ils m'ont accosté je savais pas qu'elles
étaient leurs attentions donc là c'était
assez terrible les gars ça fait deux
trois mois qui sont pas une petite
blonde dans une petite bague comme ça
se mange sans fin ça ressemble
jamais lu de livres érotiques donc il y
a beaucoup de boulot il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de boulot
quand même oui je pense
histoires assez extraordinaires alors
que la mienne est incipitée
de pas inviter la presse parce que ils
vont me chier dessus mais moi ils
paieront leur place
quand votre père voulait vous vous punir
et vous venez vivre vers lui il sortait
comme ça ça pochette il a laissé tomber
par terre il disait ramasse moi ça me
plaisait pas beaucoup parce que à chaque
fois c'est moi qui prenait tous les
coups dans la famille donc
j'étais habitué c'est plus humiliant
qu'une tarte je trouve moi ouais ça fait
moins mal quand même enfin trois quarts
d'heure de ceinturon c'est pas mal non
plus hein honnêtement je prends la
pochette
mais pas de tout ça
moi c'est Bigard c'est pour ça que
bonjour Marie on arrive au pognon
comment ils ont claqué tout ça alors
pour en revenir à votre père comment ils
l'ont bouffait le pognan
tu vas voir
où est passé la thune voilà
Jacques toucher les biceps de Péguy 49
jours sans voir la mer comme axel Bauer
toucher j'ai ressent de dire à rien
[Musique]
il s'approche de vérifier et qui lui est
touche c'est bizarre
ah voilà
c'était tout le monde en a parlé le best
of de la semaine dernière
vous êtes chez vous parce qu'on avait
question pour un champion
on a fait on va au Master junior là
un indice on passe à l'invité mystère
tout le monde est prêt donc attention on
bouge pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes né à Alger votre père
travaillait à l'EDF à Alger et vous avez
quitté l'Algérie en 62
vous êtes pieds noirs
[Musique]
avec la corde dans la bibliothèque non
alors invitez mystère vous avez une
vocation précoce à 11 ans vous jouiez
courte lignes les boulingrins c'est vrai
j'ai rien compris là en effet je traduis
si tu veux tirer en effet
alors vous étiez au Conservatoire avec
Jean-Luc Anglade Robin Renucci
Christophe Lambert vous êtes sortis du
Conservatoire à 22 ans
avant le café théâtre vous avez joué le
misanthrope
votre premier film était un film de
Roger Coggio le Misanthrope d'après
Molière
en 1991 invité mystères vous avez fait
un film de Raoul Ruiz qui s'appelle
l'oeil qui ment oui ça y est ça y est et
en 1984 la machine de François duperon
avec Gérard Depardieu vous teniez le
rôle d'un tueur psychopathe
et Olivier quelqu'un a une idée dans le
public bravo
[Musique]
Didier Bourdon l'inconnu qui joue un
extraterrestre
Didier vous connaissez
nos amis du public là en haut là au
dernier rang ils vous ont quand même
reconnu avec des trucs l'oeil qui manque
à l'huile ça va ils ont moins vu que les
trois frères
vous aviez un peu une voix
d'extraterrestre d'ailleurs exactement
exactement donc mercredi dernier est
sorti donc l'extraterrestre premier film
en solo comme réalisateur alors je vais
faire comme la télé je vais faire
ils sont payés
donc l'extraterrestre Bernard Campan
Pascal arbillaud Daniel Lebrun oui
l'histoire vous l'a raconté le pitch le
pitch hors de mots c'est un
extraterrestre qui se retrouve paumé sur
terre poursuivi par deux Android et qui
va tomber aussi sur une jeune femme qui
est paumée dans sa vie et ça va être
l'occasion d'une rencontre c'est de pas
mal de situations burlesques alors ce
qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que sur sa
planète à lui les femmes commandent et
les hommes n'ont pas le droit de baiser
sauf c'est pas ça c'est-à-dire que c'est
comme chez les insectes il y a certains
hommes qui ont le droit de baiser sont
les reproducteurs et le reste ils sont
ouvriers comiques présentateur télé
il faut se rebeller quoi et alors en
plus vous vous faites pas partie de des
baisers sur la planète non même dans la
ville d'ailleurs je fais partie des
c'est quoi c'est le contraire de baiser
c'est des baisers
j'ai dit en commençant
un soldat dans le film soldat et
poursuivi donc par deux androïdes
et Oliviera Bourdin qui joue deux
Android méchants au départ puis Bernard
Campan il va vite devenir pas gentil
c'est pas le mot mais disons que comme
il va se prendre un bus et une voiture à
travers la figure
[Musique]
la super bonne good good good good good
good good good good
extrait de
l'extraterrestre de Didier Bourdon alors
il vient d'une planète très évoluée mais
lui évidemment sur la terre il est mal à
droite et c'est un peu vous disiez comme
si un Américain débarquait en Albanie il
trouve pas de McDo quoi oui
c'est l'amour oui et puis c'est un
soldat puis surtout bon il défend sa
planète mais comme il est maltraité il
découvre un petit peu une planète
nouvelle un peu arriéré pour lui et il
est maladroit il est sensible il a peur
aussi c'est un personnage qui a peur
c'est ce qui m'a plu d'ailleurs le
personnage c'est qu'il a il a 80 000
langues en mémoire mais c'est un pauvre
mec quoi
il est toujours un peu étranger quelque
part c'est un peu une parabole votre
film ben c'est ça oui c'est à dire que
c'est un extraterrestre venu d'une autre
planète mais en fait il est traité comme
un même parfois comme un bougnole
universaliste on est tous avec quelqu'un
c'est ça qui est vrai on va regarder un
autre extrait magnifique
qu'est-ce que vous faites dans la vie
SDF
[Musique]
en France 2 jours vous connaissez que
depuis le jour et par internet
[Musique]
de la Bosnie-Herzégovine sur la miyaka
Villa dominance turque la nouvelle ville
fut construite sous domination
autrichienne à partir de 1878 université
centre artisanaux 438 764 habitants
oui oui c'est très intéressant
vous n'avez pas faim
plaisir c'est ma recette secrète
[Musique]
personnelle que personne ne trouve
jamais enfin si elle était pas plus
haute que ça ce qu'on a pu rire
[Musique]
6 g chlorure de sodium persil et petite
touche de gingembre frais
c'est un peu comme dans le pari quoi
alors je sais que vous expliquer là
dessus en ce moment ça serait bien que
on en parle aussi parce que bon vous
êtes les gens croient que vous êtes
fâchés en fait non pas du tout c'est
avec avec Paul Lederman où il y a des
problèmes mais bon je suppose que bon on
l'a expliqué moi j'ai été blessé par
cette situation je suppose que lui de
son côté aussi parce qu'on a fait quand
même un sacré parcours avec lui et
j'espère très fortement que ça va vite
se régler d'ailleurs je crois que c'est
sur le point de soleil ça va se régler
vous avez plus le droit d'apparaître en
tant qu'inconnu c'est ça non si si on va
le faire si si on a le droit non non
mais il faut qu'on règle des problèmes
entre nous il faut que les choses soient
clair et net pour que les le travail se
fasse dans la bonne humeur et dans
l'entente et comme Paul ederman est un
personnage de toute façon auquel je
tiens beaucoup parce que parce que on
raille pas il y avait une formule que
j'aimais bien c'est j'en pense trop de
mal pour en dire du bien il m'a fait
trop de bien pour en dire du mal c'est
presque un peu ça c'est à dire que je
crois qu'on s'est blessé beaucoup l'un
l'autre il y a peut-être aussi peut-être
un problème de communication tout
simplement mais je crois que les choses
vont se régler donc je suis
producteur de Coluche de l'urances
que c'était l'émission du théâtre de
Bouvard donc c'était quand même beaucoup
plus ponctuel c'était pas les mêmes
rapports affectifs qui entre Paul et
darmann et nous ça c'est sûr que polyama
on a fait toutes les télés des inconnus
c'était vraiment une période forte parce
qu'il y a une semaine vous disiez il
était que c'était que on a été naïf on a
été trois jeunes cons avec un requin ce
soir vous êtes plus sympa déjà c'est en
train de s'arranger on est ravi et là
donc vous vous avez préparé les rois
mages tout le monde c'est-à-dire que
c'est un projet qui nous tient aussi à
cœur que j'aimerais bien qu'on fasse
dans
la bonne entente c'est-à-dire c'est en
bois de réconciliation tout ça il faut
moi je veux je ne demande que ça
je sens que ça s'arrange
je sens que ça s'arrange c'est bien ça
me fait plaisir
ça s'appelle les pétales
[Musique]
je vous raconte pas la voiture si mais
j'ai loupé le permis c'est pas vrai je
suis tombé sur un mec il me l'a pas
donné tout ça parce que j'ai calé sur
une voie ferrée
du gel ça te va bien
au fait j'ai proposé à Stéphanie de
venir oh la palme
mais elle a une voiture
Stéphanie tu devrais plus y penser je
veux dire tu vas prendre une
consommation qu'est-ce que tu veux
prendre
quelque chose oui le chrono va chercher
les consommations ça te fera du bien je
prendrai un Monaco bah tiens moi aussi à
Monaco alors Stéphanie de Monaco
qu'est-ce qu'elle a qu'est-ce qui se
passe en France
[Musique]
tu sais Jean-Louis Jean-Louis Jean-Louis
Le Grand la qui ressemble à ce style
Yannick Noah Jean-Jacques Goldman tu
vois à peu près
Anthony Delon Jean-Jacques Goldman que
les mecs à la mode soyez original les
petits que tu préfères quoi Christophe
Lambert Jacques ah oui mince en parlant
de lui j'ai inversé les lentilles les
inconnus
dans les pétasses
[Musique]
bon pour rester avec nous ah ben oui
mais je crois que je dois changer de
place
maintenant quelqu'un
qui a bien connu pour le German oui
et beaucoup d'autres hommes politiques
et journalistes aujourd'hui après avoir
vécu l'enfer il revient pour nous parler
de ses chers amis c'est le titre de son
livre voici Pierre Botton
Pierre Botton bonsoir vous connaissez
pierre breton
les nouveaux inconnus
alors avant la faire Pierre Botton avant
l'affaire Botton puisqu'il est Cornu
d'appeler l'affaire breton on vous
appelait le faiseur de mer c'est vrai
que vous aviez fait lire Michel Noir à
Lyon et on vous appelait monsieur gendre
et vous avez fait lire Michel Mouillot à
Cannes et vous aviez une réussite
exemplaire disons au départ gagné
beaucoup d'argent en faisant des
affaires
le symbole de cette réussite c'était
votre villa cannoise qui faisait 554
mètres carrés sur trois niveaux pas mal
non 11 chambres dominant avec une
piscine qui dominait la baie comme ça
sympa on va on va regarder d'ailleurs
tout de suite un petit magnéto où on
voit les gens qui s'y pressaient tout le
Tout-Paris
médiatique voilà
j'étais maître d'hôtel à l'époque alors
ça alors vous disiez en parlant de cette
maison en parlant de de ce repère de Luc
je vous disiez ici pendant le festival
j'ai hébergé des ministres des
présentateurs des chanteurs
et comme il y avait des hautes
personnalités la maison était protégée
maintenant je peux laisser le portail
ouvert parce que toute façon il y a plus
rien à prendre même pas mes illusions
c'est exact et je peux rajouter aussi
que je suis plus heureux aujourd'hui
dans cette maison qui est totalement
détruite puisqu'il a fallu que je casse
250 230 m² tout seul que lorsque j'étais
entouré de ces gens qui étaient des faux
amis c'est vrai que vous larguez des
langoustes par hélicoptère dans la
piscine de la maison c'est pas vrai
c'est une légende mais vous savez entre
guillemets des des conneries j'en ai
fait pas mal et je pense que c'est sans
doute pour ce pourquoi j'ai accepté
contrairement à tous les hommes
politiques et tous les gens des affaires
qui ont été pris dans des affaires moi
contrairement à d'autres à la barre du
tribunal j'ai dit j'assume pas forcément
les fausses factures tout ça parce qu'on
voit bien que moi c'était mon argent
c'était pas l'argent des sociétés cotées
en bourse ou de contribuables mais
j'assume surtout d'avoir eu des rapports
dément avec l'argent d'avoir cru un
miroir aux alouettes qui finalement
devait me refléter moi ma réussite et en
fait ça reflétait le début de ma
déchéance humaine
vous dites donc j'y vais dans un monde
direct j'avais besoin de reconnaissance
j'étais marteau fou même pas fou
ridicule fou je ne suis peut-être
maintenant
c'est l'époque des Ferrari testaros
alors évidemment c'est le pognon quoi
la Lamborghini hein avec les piscines et
tout ça là non mais j'ai bien compris
chers amis justement où vous parlez de
tous les gens que vous avez fréquenté
vous avez fréquenté à l'époque
ça sortait Flammarion ça commence à très
bien se vendre c'est déjà 29e dans la
dans la liste du point
vous dites je veux repartir de la base
c'est avec ce bouquin je veux qu'on
sache ce qui s'est passé et je veux
repartir du départ et votre médecin vous
a conseillé de faire ce livre vous dites
je vais surtout reconstruire c'est à
dire si vous voulez je suis sorti de la
prison détruit totalement détruit
détruit exploser avec un constat sur ma
vie et une vraie difficulté à me
regarder moi-même et surtout regarder
mes enfants
donc mes enfants partent sont partis aux
États-Unis avec avec leur mère et il
faut savoir que ils ont eu leur visage
lorsqu'on a pu donner à l'administration
américaine la preuve que j'étais séparée
de corps de leur mère c'est-à-dire que
si vous voulez vous voyez bien le poids
le poids énorme de toute cette affaire
c'est exactement ce que je ne voulais
pas que moi j'ai commis des erreurs oui
que je les paye oui lourdement oui plus
lourdement que les autres encore oui
symbole par rapport à d'autres portes
peu importe tant mieux pour ceux qui
passent à travers les goûts de peu
importe c'est pas le problème mais que
mes enfants eux payent ça uniquement
parce que il porte le même nom que moi
non et là je dis non et qu'en plus
certains de mes chers amis
utilise
pour continuer à me manipuler la judiste
même quand ils sont à l'Elysée même
quand ils sont anciens gardés sceaux
même quand ils sont à la tête des plus
grands groupes moi aujourd'hui on peut
plus rien me prendre on peut me prendre
mes gosses et on me les a pris ils sont
à 8000 km si aujourd'hui il arrive
quelque chose à Anne Valérie je peux pas
aller les voir puisque j'ai plus le
droit d'aller sur le territoire
américain je suis pas sûr que Jérôme
Monod n'ait pas le droit d'aller sur le
territoire américain je pense même qu'il
y part dans l'avion du président de la
République bien alors on va parler de
vos chers amis on va faire une interview
parce que c'est que des gens connus on
peut baisser la lumière s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on va commencer donc c'est un wuzu
c'est une liste c'est une liste de gens
chacun un petit chapitre dans votre
bouquin alors on va commencer avec
quelqu'un que vous connaissez bien même
vous savez un petit peu mieux avec lui
en ce moment c'est pas le les Berman
vous ne serez pas surpris mon cher
Bordeaux quelqu'un que vous connaissez
bien Rampage 185 vous dites ça vous
raconte cette scène absolument terrible
je trouve ou après la mort de Coluche
Paul Lederman fouille le bureau de
Coluche
et sans part comme ça de cassette de
cahier comme s'il essayait de s'emparer
de tout ce qui pouvait encore avoir été
créés par Coluche avant sa mort avant
toute chose puisque vous connaissez Paul
Lederman vous connaissez ça sa tendance
procédurière et tous les gens qui sont
cités ici sont des gens très puissants
moi je ne suis plus rien aujourd'hui à
l'instant je vous parle ce livre n'est
pas attaqué c'est-à-dire à l'instant où
je vous parle d'ailleurs la première
phrase à laquelle je dédie ce livre pour
mes enfants c'est pourvu que la vérité
on peut toujours rêver qu'un jour la
vérité soit la mode aujourd'hui Paul
Lederman n'a pas attaqué ce livre donc
ce que je dis doit être la vérité
lorsque Michel est décédé il a fallu
parce que c'était comme cela Véronique
était séparée de lui d'abord et était à
Paris donc il a fallu s'occuper de
détails assez horrible c'est la première
fois que moi je m'occupais de ça pour
pour quelqu'un et il y a donc fallu
choisir ses vêtements et j'étais avec
Ludovic Paris et Éric COURLY qui était
c'est
Ludo et Eric qui était donc ces deux
copains et on est allé chercher des
vêtements et pendant que nous nous
cherchions et c'est d'ailleurs Ludovic
qui a choisi ses vêtements qui a choisi
sa salopette et tout ça et pendant que
nous nous étions en train de suivre un
moment
moi je pouvais pas croire qu'il était
mort Michel
Paul Lederman est rentré dans la pièce
et fouillait les cassettes et prenez les
cassettes et
voilà bon c'est un moment que là encore
pour solder les comptes c'est pas régler
les comptes c'est soldes j'ai besoin si
vous voulez il y a tout un ensemble de
choses que j'ai vécu j'ai besoin de les
dire et ça je l'ai vécu mais on peut les
derman n'attaque pas le livre ça veut
dire donc c'est vrai personne par
personne n'y parle président de la
République ni par sa fille ni par
Jacques Toubon ni par Jérôme Monod ni
par exemple concernant les derman qui
est terrible c'est insistant ça prend
une photo de Coluche dans son cercueil
pour la photo qui a été publiée dans
Paris Match la semaine d'après alors
j'ai absolument pas la preuve que ce
soit lui qui l'ait fait prendre ce que
je sais c'est que nous étions 7 dans
cette pièce que 6 y était opposé qu'un
seul y était favorable
et que cette photo est sortie alors dans
la série des chers amis dont vous parlez
il y a la fille du président de la
République Claude Chirac vous avez été
ami avec elle et aujourd'hui vous pensez
que cette amitié qu'elle avait pour vous
c'est en fait un calcul politique pour
infiltrer un peu l'entourage de Michel
Noir votre beau-père qui était à
l'époque en s'en souvient aurait pu être
en tous les cas un rival de Jacques
Chirac c'est à dire que là si vous
voulez il y a un moment vous savez quand
vous sortez je répète de cet isolement
vous vous demandez si vous avez vécu les
moments si vous avez vécu les choses et
là j'ai vraiment eu le besoin de de de
relire de regarder et de mettre en
annexe de mon livre cette lettre dans
laquelle c'est pas une lettre qui est
vous voyez une lettre habituelle signée
par la présence de la République ou tout
cela c'est une lettre d'émotion écrite
de sa main avec écrit je te remercie
pour ce weekend et avec écrit en toute
amitié
et voyez-vous quand vous êtes condamné à
l'isolement je parle pas de ce que je
raconte en livre du parcours que j'ai
fait je me suis présenté contre mon
beau-père à son demande mon père j'ai
fait toutes les ai toutes faites donc là
je les assure
toute faite on m'a pas mis de revolver
sur la tempe pour le faire mais il y
avait un minimum et quand on écrit en
toute amitié quand on me livre des
choses elle vivait à ce moment-là elle
aussi un moment difficile elle était
exclu de l'entourage de son père elle
vivait très mal la défaite de son de son
père en 88
la mairie de Paris avait été très très
difficile à il y avait écrit en toute
amitié et j'ai eu besoin de me dire
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire amitié pour
ces gens-là
et j'ai la réponse rien vous dites
depuis qu'elle est née elle s'ouvre la
considérez vous dites c'est une pauvre
petite fille riche en fait vous la
plaignez d'une certaine façon oui oui
alors le père Jacques Chirac c'est pas
mieux
non vous le plaignez pas vous dites des
trucs terribles vous dites
pas abordant je veux bien après Jacques
chiracle ça me déplairait pas il y a que
des Olivier à la fin du weekend
vous dites en parlant de Jacques Chirac
on vous dit homme de cœur je ne vous
connais que coeur de pierre on vous dit
généreux je ne vous connais je ne
connais que vos manœuvres enfin c'est
ainsi de suite par intérêt litanie comme
ça c'est assez violent contre lui et
vous rappelez à chaque fois dans ce
bouquin ce que vous avez fait pour tous
ces gens qui en fait on l'a bien compris
en terriblement profité de vous enfin
lui il avait besoin les pays des
affiches un autre vous l'avez payer
c'est un banquet juste je suis Ardisson
ce que je reproche à ses serres amis
c'est pas tellement ça c'est-à-dire que
si vous voulez je vous répète on m'a pas
forcé à faire moi moi j'avais envie j'ai
trouvé une reconnaissance j'ai commencé
à la plonge j'ai une réussite que je
croyais être fulgurante donc j'ai voulu
j'ai voulu être comme tout le monde
savait un ministre c'est quelque chose
qui représente tout ça ce que je
reproche c'est que moi j'ai été présent
à des moments durs
1989 il y a plus personne à côté Jacques
Chirac mais il y a pas plus Villepin que
il y a tout le monde lui tire dessus
tout le monde lui tire dessus moi je
suis en prison
encore c'est pas grave je suis en prison
il a une carrière politique ok 48 heures
après mon incarcération déjà dans un
journal on lui pose la question il me
connaît déjà plus mais plus grave que ça
me faire descendre et ce livre n'est pas
attaqué lorsque je sors de prison pour
la deuxième fois
on me reçoit à l'Elysée à l'heure
demande là encore je répète mon livre
n'est pas attaqué ma version et donc
exacte je livre les numéros de téléphone
privés je livre le numéro de la personne
là qui m'arrête dans la rue et qui me de
me dit que Monsieur pourquoi vous ne
prenez pas contact avec l'Élysée alors
je dis si c'est ça
pourquoi pour continuer à me manipuler
il fallait que je descende jusqu'où et
là j'ai dit stop c'est pour ça que j'ai
une liberté de ton extraordinaire
vis-à-vis du président de la République
il est président de la République je ne
suis plus rien mais moi je l'ai connu
pas grand chose et j'estime qu'il y
avait un devoir excusez-moi parce que
moi j'ai été condamné je suis privé de
mes droits civiques il est président de
la République plus aucun juge peut plus
rien pour lui je suis employé un mot que
je devrais pas employer un devoir de
morale sentimentale
et ça il l'a pas eu à mon égard ni à
l'égard de mes enfants ni à l'égard de
ma femme alors vous étiez pierre breton
très fasciné effectivement par le
personnel politique c'est-à-dire aussi
bien les ministres enfin tous les que
les gens de télévision c'est quelque
chose qui a l'air de nous passionné la
fréquentation des gens qui me
passionnait qui me passionnait mais
c'est vrai que la fréquentation des gens
de télévision pour vous par exemple
Françoise closet je sais pas si vous
passeriez vos weekends et François
closet
alors François closet vous l'invitiez à
Saint après vous avez même envoyé une
lettre au juge quand il a été accusé une
lettre juge pour le disculper et en fait
lui alors ça c'est incroyable un jour il
voit une photo dans dans Paris Match où
il y a il est là avec Poivre d'Arvor
avec Michel Noir Mouillot et vous et il
attaque par image parce qu'il a été en
photo avec vous
la seule différence qu'il y a entre la
photo que vous avez montré qui est en
1992 mai 92 je suis on va dire au summum
summum de la bêtise et puis l'autre
c'est que l'autre elle sort assez jour
d'un procès donc voilà mais ce qui est
encore plus grave c'est que non
seulement Paris Match est condamné mais
ça ne lui suffit pas il veut encore il
continue pour gagner 15000 francs qu'il
gagne d'ailleurs ouais à ce niveau là je
crois qu'il faut raconter ça parce que
si vous voulez à ce niveau là de
trahison de bassesse mais qui que ce
soit je veux dire c'est il s'avère que
c'est François de clausat et Janine
Jossin qui que ce soit alors que je
publie le mot dans lequel il est écrit
je me retourne tu es déjà à la télé ne
fais pas comme Coluche je t'en supplie
merci pour ce weekend de détente à 16
jours du procès il attaque un journal
mais qu'est-ce que c'est je voudrais je
vous répète qu'il m'oublie normal
qu'il me charge alors que je l'épreuve
que vous avez non Jean-Pierre Cabasse
aussi notre ancien président en
septembre 99 dans une salle de sport il
fait semblant de pas vous reconnaître
pas tout à fait ça ah oui expliquez-moi
non c'est pas tout à fait ça veut dire
qu'il voit que je suis là il remonte il
se pose la question et puis il revient
et puis et ce moment-là il vient et puis
il vient me voir et puis il passe à côté
de moi il dit ben puisqu'on est là on
peut se saluer et vous savez quand
j'étais en prison j'ai pris j'ai pris
une certaine habitude c'est-à-dire que
parfois il y a des moments très
difficiles en prison il y a des choses
que vous ne voulez pas entendre il y a
des choses que auxquelles vous ne voulez
pas penser alors vous faites des pompes
c'est pour ça que tous les gars qui font
de la prison sont très baraqués et donc
j'ai continué à faire mes pompes sans le
regarder
et il est repassé il est revenu et il a
dit il est il a ré-attaqué en disant
quand même tu pourrais me dire bonjour
et le monsieur qui est à côté de lui
pensait que c'était à lui que ça
s'adresse à Eddy excusez-moi mais je ne
vous connais pas et il dit c'est un
monsieur Botton je m'adresse voilà mais
j'ai plus envie que ces gens m'adresse
la parole c'est pour ça aujourd'hui
c'est clair je pense que là je pense que
là
concernant Jean-Pierre alkabba je vous
dites que vous lui avez fait cadeau d'un
téléviseur
et alors il dit oui mais attendez moi
j'ai appelé Botton pour savoir combien
je lui devait et vous vous dites pas du
tout il a juste appelé parce que il
savait pas qu'il payait pour régler les
chaînes qu'il attaque le livre oui non
mais voilà je veux dire il risque plus
de vous péter si vous voulez ce que je
trouve un petit peu quand même choquant
là c'est que Jean-Pierre Elkabbach il
évolue dans le milieu depuis 30 ans
moi à la limite je vous répète j'ai payé
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai le droit de
parler j'aurais pu faire ce livre à la
veille de mon procès
je le fais alors que c'est soldé j'ai
fait ma prison plein pot bien ce que je
trouve choquant c'est que voilà voilà
quelqu'un donc qui est dans le système
depuis 20 ans il accepte un téléviseur
de quelqu'un dont il dit puisque je
publie son interrogatoire chez les
instruction donc je vais mettre face à
ces mots
il dit bah non j'étais pas assez ami
pour accepter un téléviseur et puis je
le vois il y a 48 heures je ne connais
pas Christine de vigencourt ça
m'intéresse pas jouer le juge
d'instruction devant Christine de bijoux
là encore pour moi uniquement pour moi
ce livre il est fait pour moi je savais
que je touche pas un franc puisque là
ce qui me donne là encore une grande
liberté de parole pour moi je trouve ça
exceptionnel il y a aussi Bernard Pivot
alors Bernard Pivot vous l'avez beaucoup
invité dans des dans des dîners près
l'avion et Platini tout ça et un jour il
vous rencontre garde Lyon après vos
problèmes et vous dites il se fige dans
une espèce de demi-tour extrêmement
habile comme ça du très grand arbre et
c'est normal
[Applaudissements]
il faut dire également qu'il y a des
gens qui ont exceptionnels alors
justement on fait comment on
enchaînement il y a pierre alors
incroyable mais vrai PPD alors lui c'est
vous dites c'est mon ami et pourtant il
en a fait lui des séjours gratuits à
Cannes et des tours en hélicoptère
mais il vous a jamais lâché vous dites
même dans le bureau du juge et vous
dites c'est mon ami aujourd'hui il ne se
détourne pas oui je veux dire sur
Patrick d'abord c'est vrai je le dis
dans le livre c'est vrai qu'il a fait
des tours en hélicoptère c'est vrai
qu'il a pas payé grand-chose mais il a
été condamné et il a payé 200000 balles
il a été condamné et puis vous savez une
fois que j'ai été incarcéré la deuxième
fois
bien Patrick un jour m'a dit tu sais
pierre ton nom j'en peux plus parce que
chaque fois que j'entends non on me
rappelle que j'ai été condamné il aurait
très bien pu faire comme plein d'autres
m'oublier 30 mai 1996 je suis incarcéré
je peux plus rien lui apporter plus rien
je suis un poids pour lui il me souhaite
mon anniversaire il m'écrit et puis
cette anecdote exceptionnelle monsieur
Ardisson exceptionnel je suis dans un
endroit dans un restaurant puis j'ai une
gamine qui vient me voir et puis qui me
dit bonjour vous me reconnaissez je lui
dis non excusez-moi elle me fait je suis
Morgane Poivre d'Arvor et je tenais
absolument à vous embrasser
et vous voyez quand la gamine a cette
démarche là c'est que au repas de
famille mon appareil mon nom il est pas
banni alors bon on va pas passer tout
Paris en revue parce que normalement
je vous garantis qu'on pourrait alors je
vais terminer avec Charles Villeneuve
donc qui travaille sur TF1 et alors lui
il dit il a affirmé lui pas avoir
profité de transport d'hôtel alors
évidemment là vous êtes vous avez
carrément vous donner les facs
similaires les factures d'hélico des
billets d'avion des locations de ski et
vous étiez sympa comme copains
parce que vous payez même les locations
de ski concernant Charles Villeneuve je
produis même la facture où il m'a laissé
même dans un hôtel 50 francs de chocolat
et payer les mini bar aussi
alors vous parlez concernant Charles
Villeneuve donc il y a des villas la
villa de Cannes évidemment c'est le
fameux villa où tout le monde allait
tout le monde
est mouillé la piscine bravo la piscine
de Botton tout le monde est mouillé
600 de jours de prison alors il faisait
arriver un truc terrible aussi c'est que
tapis parce que vous étiez fait attendez
vous vous retrouvez en prison c'est
horrible ça c'est l'huile de tapis tiens
c'est vrai ça sur le mec avec qui tu es
fâché tu te retrouves face à face alors
vous voulez lui faire la pause énervé
contre lui hein c'est Madame Vasseur qui
raconte ça dans son bouquin j'ai pas
inventé et alors tellement vous vous
ennuyez tous les deux vous avez fini par
jouer à la belote ensemble
j'ai toujours refusé non non non non non
non non mais vous aviez vous avez plus
rien
excusez-moi c'est vous vous faites et
c'est normal votre vous exercez votre
talent moi sur la prison je peux pas
j'ai un ami
là-dessus concernant tapis moi j'ai
tourné la page mais d'accord
ça ça c'est une question qui est vrai
que nous étions l'un en face de moi
c'était un petit peu
tordue de la part du patron de la prison
nous mettre en face non mais vous savez
je crois que les gens connaissent pas ce
que c'est qu'une incarcération vous
savez quand vous êtes détenus la
première chose qu'on fait on fait votre
photo et on vous met un matricule
vraiment vous n'êtes plus rien
aujourd'hui vous travaillez à mi-temps
dans une affaire de communication
vos salaires au-dessus au dessus de 9000
francs sont saisis et vous avez combien
de dettes encore à rembourser 28
millions 28 millions c'est bien
le principal trésorier de à qui je dois
20 millions puisqu'il y a cette
trésorerie en France m'a dit nous avons
deux choix monsieur Botton soit espérer
que vous fassiez fortune soit vous soyez
Mathusalem parce qu'on a fait le calcul
ça fait 812 ans qu'elle vous ne
remboursez
moi je préférais l'histoire de
l'extraterrestre qui a paniqué là
c'est mieux quand même parce que ça
c'est un peu triste comme scénario c'est
l'autre solution pour beton c'est de
repartir sur la planète là
évidemment ça va dû vous mettre dans un
état formidable ça vous dites j'ai 44
ans je suis totalement déséquilibré vous
dites je suis un petit peu tout le temps
au bord des larmes et je voudrais
arrêter les médicaments prenez beaucoup
de médicaments
vous avez fait une tentative de suicide
en prison
on peut arrêter peut-être d'en parler
[Musique]
avec nous
alors maintenant je vais accueillir
quelqu'un de tout de suite la
reconnaître je suis au service
bonsoir
vous connaissez cette chanson de Claude
François je suis au service de France
[Applaudissements]
vous connaissez Cécile
vous avez commencé donc vous a connu
effectivement pour cette météo de Canal+
et vous avez vous avez commencé par un
gros coup de bol vous vous promenez dans
les couloirs du Martinez vous tombez
vous tombez sur Alain de greffe le
patron des programmes de Canal+ et il
vous propose de présenter la météo
en fait moi j'étais mannequins et ils
ont fait un casting dans différentes
agences pour trouver une jeune fille
pour faire un Clara sur Internet c'était
l'histoire d'une jeune comédienne à
Cannes comment roman photo sur Internet
en fait
[Musique]
vous dites d'ailleurs Cécile Simone avec
beaucoup de Cécile dit avec beaucoup de
franchise
j'ai des petits seins mais c'est ce que
je préfère chez moi ah non jugement
sexuel que pendant 3 minutes vous disais
ça à l'époque de la météo après vous
mettiez vos jeans vos baskets et pour
devenir ce que vous considérez comme une
bombe sexuelle parce que les gens
applaudissaient beaucoup
à barboton quand il arrivait avec le
président d'hélicoptère sur la Croisette
et j'ai mis autant d'émeutes que pour
vous non c'est vrai
plus de succès qu'une fille qui avait la
palme d'or
il y a aussi des des
gens me connaissaient tous les jours
quoi donc bon c'est vrai qu'ils
s'habitue à vous et qui vous aime bien
un jour ou
non mais c'est Sylvie je suis pas assez
féministe pour voir ça d'un mauvais œil
c'est comme un rôle elle le dit vous
avez pas le complexe de la petit je vous
non parce que je me suis jamais pour moi
enfin les gens me parlaient souvent de
ça me disaient est-ce que ça vous gêne
pas d'être petit je trouve ça moi je me
suis jamais senti potiche parce que on
m'a pris pour faire la météo parce que
j'étais jolie et j'en étais consciente à
la base donc effectivement
enfin je me suis jamais vraiment posé de
questions par rapport à ça ça m'a jamais
gêné et les gens avec qui je travaillais
me considéraient pas comme une potiche
maintenant il y a toujours des mauvaises
langues qui vous voient comme une
potiche et puis d'autres qui vous trou
qui sont ravis de vous voir arriver pour
la météo et qui sont contents de vous
voir avec des nouvelles fringues
quand même vous avez fait une entrée de
chance et mini-jupe et le cadreur il
s'est mis un peu mais
mais non mais c'était j'ai vu après on a
rien vu mais j'ai été le voir juste
après puis je te dis ouais ouais
remonte un peu la caméra quand je rentre
et c'est vrai qu'il y a des dents qui
vous a proposé un million de francs
il était très excusez-moi pierre et
c'est vrai c'est dispendieux un peu
Pierre Botton
un mec a proposé à Cécile siméone un
million de francs alors rien du tout
et je l'avais mis au mur comme ça pour
rigoler pour rien et j'ai jamais été
vérifié même si il était solvable en
fait
je veux pas citer non parce que je veux
pas balancer non plus mais bon
bon Cécile il y a juste un petit
problème quoi dites-moi parce que là
quand on vous voit tout ce que vous nous
dites tout ça pas de complexe de la
petite ça pas mignonne tout et puis un
petit problème vous êtes un peu un peu
feignant
je suis toujours été c'est vrai je le
reconnais tout de suite
j'étais tranquille quoi avec moi
on est à Lyon
vous étiez destinatrice à Lyon et vous
avez quitté Lyon sur un coup de tête
vous avez quitté canal sur un coup de
tête aussi non
pouvais pas quitter canal sur un coup de
tête en fait pendant mes trois ans à
Canal j'ai eu quelques expériences
non ah non non
j'ai fait premièrement la première année
à un cinéma théâtre avec marcologne ça
fait marcelone et je savais pas que
j'étais je pouvais jouer je me demandais
j'ai essayé ça s'est bien passé ça m'a
beaucoup plu après j'ai fait un moyen
métrage et un court-métrage et j'ai
beaucoup aimé le fait de jouer et je me
suis dit je vais le tenter là donc pour
moi j'ai pas été conseillé mais dans ma
tête je me disais que la télé le cinéma
n'était pas compatible
j'ai choisi le cinéma j'ai choisi j'ai
choisi d'arrêter la télé et de voir ce
qu'elle allait se passer
vous êtes pas quitté canal pour vous
marier c'est pas du tout ça
grande vous connaissez vous oh
le gardien de but du PSG Bernard
vous ressemblez vous dites on se
ressemble avec Dominique Casagrande on
se ressemble et c'est bien vous croyez
que c'est bien de se ressembler avec son
avec son jules
enfin j'ai eu l'expérience avec quelques
personnes à qui j'ai vécu effectivement
d'être trop opposé non ça marche pas je
trouve moi non enfin je trouve que non
non on se ressemble on a envie des mêmes
choses on est bien quoi et vous êtes
heureuse avec lui
entre mes chers amis
vous qui quitteriez pas Dominique
Casagrande sur un coup de tête
[Musique]
avec Casa Grande
[Applaudissements]
dernier coup de tête dernier coup de
tête c'est en partant peut-être ouais de
la télé
coup de poing c'est plutôt une
engueulade en voiture voilà avec la
on a lancé un appel dans l'émission ça
super bien marché personne n'a appelé
dernier coup de rouge
en famille pour les 20 ans de ma sœur
c'était le 19 janvier
dernier coup de chapeau c'est compliqué
la suivante est mieux dernier coup de
main
je comprends pourquoi il perdent
toujours
dernier coup de blues
on peut rallumer
merci merci Cécile siméone vous restez
avec nous c'est vous qui allez faire la
fille
et j'accueille maintenant une vraie
médaille d'or mesdames messieurs Jamel
Bouras
alors donc Jamel Boras médaille d'or de
judo aux Jeux Olympiques d'Atlanta en 96
un an plus tard contre les positifs à
l'endroit l'aune et vous parlez de ça
dans un vent parler donc dans un bouquin
voilà
on commence alors commence par
l'histoire de votre famille justement
votre
votre grand-père qui a fait 14-18
c'est pas mal de le dire ça
oui tout à fait en fait j'ai voulu faire
j'ai voulu raconter un peu le 12 venais
ça va être de mon arbre un peu commencé
et je crois que c'est important surtout
je voulais que les Français de souche
parce que moi j'ai une double culture je
voulais qu'on comprenne une fois pour
toutes nos difficultés c'est qu'en fait
c'est-à-dire il nous disait toujours
qu'on était algérien moi personnellement
je suis né en France mais mes parents me
disaient algériens on va retourner
définitif en Algérie on est pas chez
nous aussi d'accord et tout moi j'étais
à la maison bon c'est ça et lorsque
j'arrivais lorsque j'allais à l'école
de quelle origine je suis algérien mais
tu es né en France c'est pas possible
on avait le cul entre deux chaises donc
il fallait acheter il fallait trouver
son canapé à quel âge vous avez
découvert le judo parce que vous avez
découvert le judo vous dites je vis judo
je dors judo je cours judo je ne rêve
que de combat et de victoire c'est à
quel âge ça j'ai commencé le judo
j'avais 8 ans et je pense que c'est vers
12 12 13 ans c'est à dire que même
lorsque mon père me disait bon ben c'est
d'école moi le judo ça m'intéresse pas
donc c'est l'école lorsqu'il donnait des
livres il fallait que je lui résume les
chapitres un peu le soir donc j'étais là
dans les bouquins au bout d'une
demi-heure je me rends compte j'avais
j'avais rien lu quoi j'étais dans une
finale de une compétition je ne sais pas
première ceinture noire j'ai même pas le
droit de l'apporter parce que vous êtes
obligé de moi la porter à 16 ans et en
88 alors ça c'est incroyable dans le
genre passion en 88 vous voulez
tellement participer au championnat de
France vous avez une jambe cassée vous
cassez le plâtre ça c'est non c'est je
je me fais une double entorse râchement
du ligament et on me met le plâtre le
soir même et mon père qui me disait non
non et le soir il a fallu que je
convaincre pour qu'il le soir même il
m'a si le plâtre et j'ai fait toute une
galère de rééducation avec le la lampe
Kim chauffe le pied le l'entraîneur qui
me massait qui me pour sinon pour moi
les chemins de France étaient foutu
après vous partez à jouer un ville parce
que beaucoup de sportifs vont Joinville
pour faire l'armée et là justement
l'alcool vous permet vous buviez pas
évidemment en tant que musulman chez
vous et l'alcool vous permet de faire
partie du groupe de vous intégrer un
petit peu avec les autres et c'est là
qu'il y a cette scène terrible c'est à
dire 193 au Japon stage de de l'équipe
de France après une soirée arrosée vous
avez un ami qui se fait renverser par
une voiture et qui meurt le lendemain à
l'hôpital j'étais là vous dites tous les
deux avec
douillet la main dans la main c'est que
lorsque je suis arrivé à j'avais 16-17
ans
et comme j'étais souvent dans ma cité
là-bas on est toujours entre nous ils
ont toujours fait ça pour qu'on soit
toujours entre nous de toute façon
lorsque je suis arrivé à Paris ça a été
une ouverture pour moi mais lorsque
j'arrive j'étais toujours entouré de
Français de souche quoi ou de chrétiens
qui pour eux l'alcool n'était pas
interdit ou quoi que ce soit et moi je
savais pas je croyais en Dieu mais bon
j'étais pas pratique quand et donc
autour de tout ça dès que les gens ont
commencé à boire moi j'étais autour
alors ça rigolait pour pipi caca pour
n'importe quoi donc j'étais là toujours
en dehors je me faisais je me faisais
chier quoi j'étais là ça alors je
rentrais toujours dans la chambre tout
le temps tout le temps j'étais un peu
seul et puis un moment donné je me suis
dit bon bah je de toute façon je
pratique pas je vais faire partie de
leur trip quoi et jusqu'à un moment où
il y a eu cet accident au Japon et je
reviens vous êtes rentré de boire quoi
j'ai étudié j'ai après j'ai commencé à
lire des livres sur déjà je me suis posé
la question sur la croyance
y a-t-il un dieu ou pas donc j'ai fait
un peu des recherches personnelles et
puis ça aussi aussi c'est c'est notre
cœur qui le sont c'est pas vraiment
aussi une réelle a raison parce qu'on
dit toujours que le cœur dépasse la
raison vous étiez le premier musulman
français donc champion olympique en 96
et vous dédiez votre médaille d'or au
monde musulman ça choqué beaucoup de
gens sachez des oui bah de toute façon
l'ignorance chaque beaucoup de gens ce
genre c'est pour ça qu'on dit que
l'ignorance engendre la crainte et la
crainte enjeux de la haine et le monde
musulman c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses qui je laisse comme je l'explique
dans le livre c'est qu'il y a beaucoup
de choses qui n'avaient choqué cette
année-là moi en tant que musulman
lorsque c'est à dire qu'on n'était pas
on ne jugeait pas de la même façon
lorsque c'était un autre personne qui
est musulman
je donne un exemple au Liban ils ont tué
il y a eu je sais pas 104 morts à cette
époque là civile et il y a eu beaucoup
moins de morts je me rappelle en Israël
il y a eu quatre morts on a donné 100
millions de dollars à l'Assemblée
nationale ils ont fait une minute de
silence j'ai dit qu'elle c'est super
c'est beau ce qu'on fait dans le monde
c'est extraordinaire alors et ensuite il
y a eu 104 civils morts et la personne
n'a rien fait à 10 minutes de silence et
j'ai dit pourquoi c'est comme ça et une
autre chose aussi qui va chauffer que ce
qui m'a choqué c'est que en Bosnie avec
ce qui se passait
pas de pétrole et rien donc les gens ne
venaient pas là-bas et en plus il y a
une autre chose si ça avait été le
contraire et j'en suis un peu persuadé
si ça avait été les Bosniaques qui
massacrer les Serbes on aurait dit ah
les fous de Dieu sont en train de
massacrer les pauvres chrétiens ou les
folles et c'est ça que j'apprécie pas
c'est que sur les 1 milliards 300
millions de dans le monde il suffit
qu'il y ait un petit pourcentage
d'ignorants
qui ou de feu
en exergue les les intégristes et les
fondamentalistes
pour moi c'est fait exprès parce que
souvent les musulmans qu'on interroge
aussi on dirait qu'on les choisit parce
que on a envie de montrer ça et il y a
beaucoup de musulmans qui sont très
sages qui sont très qui est très peu qui
ont un respect de la femme que il y a
même pas un Européen j'ai pas vu un
Européen un ami européen respecter sa
femme comme ça et ça on le montre jamais
bourrasque des musulmans s'expriment à
la télévision en France pour parler de
la religion à part le dimanche matin
quand on dort pourquoi parce que oui non
mais d'accord parce que
c'est pas ça c'est que c'est mal dans la
mentalité maintenant c'est mal perçu
lorsqu'on je suis musulman les gens même
ceux qui sont musulmans en honte presque
c'est à dire
ils ont honte de dire où je suis
musulman je fais le ramadan je fais si
avant parce que dès que tu dis ça bah tu
vois on se met un peu à l'écart
qu'est-ce qui va nous faire il va nous
catholiques maintenant quand quelqu'un
dit je suis catholique on dit je vais
être de droite comme s'il y a de
catholique ça voulait dire de droite
alors que je pense pas franchement
beaucoup moins peut-être un peu
maintenant mais beaucoup moins et c'est
dommage je trouve
alors après votre après votre victoire
évidemment les médias se sont jetés sur
vous vous parlez de JP qui vous attendez
vous l'avez pas regardé il était là pour
se faire mousser
c'est clair je veux dire pourquoi j'ai
dit pourquoi je le dis ça parce que je
le pensais c'est à dire que tous les
sportifs déjà dans l'avion faisait ça de
toute façon tellement les les sportifs
de la fête à l'intérieur tout le monde
est arrivé les chemises déchirées torse
nuée personne n'a vu Juppé mais ils sont
là
c'est qui toi personne n'a fait
attention quoi et puis je dis c'est ils
sont là pour faire pour se faire mousser
parce que dans mon épreuve l'épreuve que
j'ai eu
on en a toujours de façon mais dans
l'épreuve que j'ai eu c'est à dire que
lorsqu'on a besoin d'eux je parle pas de
Juppé pour tous les politiques
lorsque tu réussis le emblème en ce
moment avec Zidane tu vois ils sont tous
là si Zidane il a besoin d'eux ils sont
là en garde à vous ils vont tous avec le
dernier et moi lorsque je les ai lorsque
j'ai eu mon enfin lorsque je suis revenu
oui Jamel alors il y a pas de problème
et cetera tu vois comme tu veux ta
famille tu viens tout ce que tu veux tu
vois et quand j'ai mon problème
excusez-moi là mais je il y a une je
suis innocent là il y a vraiment une
injustice qui est en train de se passer
etc oui vous savez il est pas là il est
en Afrique là ils sont pas là tu vois
c'est pas ça
qui nous a réuni et puis comme j'ai un
peu plus de bouteilles que toi ah ça
c'est clair
je lui je me suis permis de lui dire
qu'il fallait peut-être avoir un peu
plus de recul parce que
c'est très difficile pour quelqu'un
comme Jamel qui a été touché je voudrais
juste si c'est possible que tu montres
tes mains à mes doigts tes doigts tes
doigts parce que vous voyez pour être
champion olympique il a déformé ses
mains et regarder
donc quand on souffle comme ça pour être
champion olympique on est attaqué il y a
deux façons de réagir et c'est vrai je
parle sous le contrôle de Jamel c'est
vrai que par rapport à ses origines par
rapport à ce qu'il a il avait peut-être
plutôt tendance à se réfugier dans la
haine et plutôt que tourner la page et
de démontrer seulement qu'il était le
plus fort et je crois qu'aujourd'hui on
va devant soi quelqu'un qui est fort
alors
dans cette
dans ce que vous avez gagné cette
médaille vous avez beaucoup de succès
donc évidemment Juppé qui vous attend
etc vous le regardez même pas et le
cinéma vous tombe dessus c'est un peu la
même histoire que Florent Pagny vous
êtes tombé sur Dominique bessenard
que j'avais rencontré avant d'être avant
d'être avant d'être proposé des rôles de
maghrébin beau gosse amoureux d'une
bourgeoise avec des scènes d'amour si
vous avez pas branché une dizaine là
depuis mais c'est on m'a proposé une
fois un scénar alors c'était soi-disant
voilà maghrébin qui habite dans un
village qui sort avec toutes les filles
et là ton amoureux d'une fille du Front
national quoi super
on va proposer un autre je vous donne un
autre le deuxième c'est je travaille je
te fais livreur chez Pizza etc et puis
je tombe dans un dans une banque et je
me retrouve avec une bourgeoise et puis
on a enchaîné tous les deux et puis
après on se retrouve en amour que des
pions que des premiers rôles en plus tu
vois pour un début c'est super vous avez
vu la légion
de chanter la Marseillaise comment on
dit il faut trembler pour grandir et
puis à cette époque là quand tu es un
peu dans les nuages tu fais pas gaffe à
plein de choses et puis bon je déjà que
je suis assez rebelle comme ça je me
suis dit bon si je déjà que j'ai acheté
en 96 et j'essaie de dire beaucoup de
choses alors si je me suis dit je me
fais remarquer encore pour ça et on a
vraiment ça va celui-là
et c'est pour ça mais c'est vrai que
avec réflexion je me dis mais pourquoi
je l'ai accepté quoi pour moi ça ça sert
à rien une jambe au nord je sais pas
quand je les ai appelés quand je les ai
appelé quand j'ai mon problème ça
personne
être dans votre livre qui s'appelle
alors là on dirait du beau temps l'heure
des trahisons et vous dites les amis du
champion olympique ont du mal à être
ceux du dopé ma chance dans tout ça
c'est que je fais du sport de combat
donc dans la rue les gens se disent pas
on va le dire tiens tu es dopé tu es si
parce que on sait jamais si il est un
peu fait d'être dessus tu vois donc ça
déjà ça m'a sauvé un peu mais
le plus il m'a touché c'est ma famille
c'est lorsqu'on a une petite sœur qui
est charmante qui est magnifique à 12
ans qui va à l'école Anissa qui revient
en pleurant à qui parle de l'école parce
que tu as tous ces copains c'est
compréhensible en plus à cet âge-là de
toute façon à 12-13 ans on est toujours
un peu vache et ton frère c'est un
tricheur ou quoi que ce soit qui revient
en pleurant qui va pas l'école pendant
un temps et enfin ma mère la douleur
qu'elle a parce que même si j'ai beau
avoir maintenant 25 28 ans ou je serai
toujours son bébé quoi et lorsqu'il y a
un problème et ses amis là quand ils
m'ont appelé ils m'ont pas dit mais
qu'est-ce que tu as fait me rappeler mon
qu'est-ce qu'ils t'ont fait qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé et cette fois cette fois
là j'ai ma famille vous savez nous quand
on jure peut-être qu'elle a notre époque
ça ne veut plus rien dire quand on jure
sur quelque chose
on est obligé de nous croire
sachant que moi j'ai des la médaille
d'or dans une langue donc ils se disent
les musulmans lorsque quand je suis
arrivé là-bas quand je suis descendu à
Givors je leur ai dit tout simplement
parce que j'ai une fille qui s'appelle
Inès et je leur ai dit que Dieu
aujourd'hui me maudit
moi ma fille ma famille si moi j'ai fait
ça ils sont mis à pleurer en fait parce
qu'ils savent de quoi je parle tu vois
savais qu'il y avait une c'était assez
grave c'est assez fort tu peux me
permettre de dire
Jamel vit quelque chose que tous les
gens qui ont été condamnés à un moment
vive il est aujourd'hui blanchi et
pourtant vous lui reposez des questions
sur son passé et il continue à y
répondre tu dois plus répondre à ces
questions de Jamal parce qu'on t'a rendu
ta médaille
donc ça n'a plus lieu d'être tourne à
Paris
aujourd'hui j'ai appris une bonne chose
c'est que je vais l'emmener à chaque
fois dans les émissions
à tous les Djamel Bouras de cette terre
c'est dans combien de temps Sydney là
septembre
fait ouais alors là je sais plus ce
qu'ils vont me faire j'espère je leur
demande juste une fois c'est de ne rien
faire de ne rien faire avant pour que je
puisse y aller mais voilà merci tu vois
et puis voilà quoi
alors mon invité suivant
la piscine comme ça
[Musique]
salut
[Applaudissements]
vous sortez un album il s'appelle trop
jeune pour mourir
trop jeune pour mourir donc entièrement
écrit à la campagne ouais non pas
70% en des textes sans alcool sans
pétard sans alcool sans pétard sans
femme sans rien avec beaucoup
de
concentration être tranquille
ou les pétards
en même temps alors il y a ça la trop
jeune pour mourir
[Musique]
j'ai passé une chanson sur le sur
l'esclavage
c'est une chanson sur l'esclavage et
pour pousser un peu les choses à faire
que Monsieur Chirac ou le prochain
président fasse en sorte que il y a un
22 mai fériés jour de l'abolition de
l'esclavage ça serait bien pour qui est
la reconnaissance pour tout le mal que
la France a fait et l'Europe l'Occident
les États-Unis qui ne reconnaissances
une pierre à la diffusion respect avant
de m'efférer ça serait bien toutes les
plus belles tribus africaines qui
défileront sur les Champs-Élysées ce
serait ce serait bien pour qu'on reparte
bien pour ce [__] de nouveau
millénaire si l'émission rebelle ce soir
il y en a une autre qui s'appelle
incendie dans mon paradis c'est une
histoire d'amour qui tourne mal comme le
titre le dit c'est une histoire à 20 ans
entre moi et les filles
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
me pardonner alors ça c'est une autre
chanson
ma famille mes amis et bien sûr à toi va
chier tu m'accroches à la vie
[Musique]
c'est pas mal cet album là bravo hein je
rappelle le titre trop jeune pour mourir
merci c'est disponible
il y a une chanson sur votre chien le
plus de boule avec vous dites qu'il a
les oreilles pas coupées pour qu'il
ressemble à labrador mais ce qu'il
allait les couilles coupées parce que
c'était labrador il faut leur couper les
couilles là j'ai pas encore j'ai pas
encore fait mais je pense c'est pas bien
cette chanson il y a les chiens qui font
les chiennes qui font comment je sais
pas le faire
le clip de ça on ne verra pas dans la
dans le clip on verra que le petit pit
est en train de conduire des BMW il
s'arrête devant un pavillon et ici il y
a une un collet qui sort une femelle
Lassie qui sauve qui parle avec lui en
vadrouille tout ça il y a une tombe à la
place du cœur aussi avec Jacques Dutronc
c'est très très bien là il y a de la
guitare là il y a un peu de la guitare
électrique influence influence du tronc
ouais j'adore la guitare électrique
j'adore du tronc depuis que je suis
petit et puis Arsène Lupin et j'adore sa
voix son attitude les textes
c'est de la bombe et puis alors il y a
la chanson dont tout le monde va parler
mais ta tête dedans
c'est un titre c'est un anime
garçon si tu veux pas certaines choses à
ta copine fais-le sinon aller ravoir
ailleurs ou bien aux gens
elle est bien
qu'en Afrique
les mecs le font pas parce qu'ils ont
l'impression de déroger de faire ce
qu'on appelle un cunnilingus
si je fais des titres comme ça c'est
j'ai pas envie de j'ai pas envie d'être
tenir
un exemple ni un bon exemple juste moi
j'arrive prenez-moi comme ça ou pas j'ai
pas envie de faire des choses pour
essayer de passer bien faire le gentil
[__]
mon côté sec j'ai mon côté rebelle j'ai
mon côté lover j'ai plein de plein de
personnages en moi et dans ma musique ça
ça se ressent mais ça sympa pour les
filles moi je suis aucune raison de
s'excuser d'avoir fait ça non mais je
sais pas comment ça s'appelle moi je dis
que nilingus c'est un peu con c'est vrai
que
cuni avant avant il y a des [__] dans
le quartier disait langue forêt
bisous je dis bisous
en bas bisous en bas
ça fait deux
Biber
c'est un gangster mais c'est un lover
moi je crois que vous êtes lover en fait
parce que vous êtes du Cap Vert enfin
originaire du Cap Vert et que vous avez
une influence portugaise latine quoi
vous êtes latine latine lover non c'est
pour ça doit être un peu ça doit y faire
non votre nom c'est du Arté
j'ai le doigt c'est l'ancienne colonie
portugaise ils sont où vos cheveux là ça
y est j'en avais marre ça c'est
vachement beau ouais mais en fin de
compte c'est quand j'étais avec une
fille
c'est difficile pour moi
encore
là aujourd'hui je suis à l'aise je peux
en parler mais c'est quand j'étais avec
une fille et le lendemain j'avais une
télé ou un concert elle pouvait pas me
toucher bien les cheveux sinon mes
traces ils allaient partir un truc là je
leur mets avec un bandana c'était
c'était saoulant donc j'avais envie
d'arriver plus nature plus vrai tête
rasé torse nu je suis là j'arrive on y
va quand on voit la pochette zoom mon
garçon tu vois comment il est bâti le
garçon hein on dirait jamais le pouvoir
je sais pas si je me trompe non il est
pas Tupac il a pas fait hein
il a fini comme ça
très très bien vous raconter une époque
où vous étiez un peu bon on peut
découvrir quoi
non mais c'est très beau ce qu'il dit
gentleman gentleman
je rentrais dans un appartement je
fouillais je trouvais des photos
d'enfants des trucs personnels de gens
qui ont travaillé comme mon père comme
ma mère et je me dégoûtais je ressortais
par la fenêtre sans rien prendre
je suis un gangster d'amour j'ai un cœur
c'est bien
arrivé des ordinateurs dans les bureaux
on vous aime quand vous dites des choses
comme ça et alors quand votre fils est
né vous êtes arrêté de déconner quoi
vous allez voir la NPE et là on vous a
demandé enfin vous a demandé à demander
mais on vous a filé comme boulot de
transporter des sacs de ciment ou un
jour ça m'a gavé transporter des sacs de
ciment en faisant insulter c'était chaud
parce que quand j'étais plus petit quand
j'ai raté l'école je faisais des
chantiers avec mon père bon c'était avec
mon père même si on travaille dur quand
j'étais un peu plus un peu fatigué me
disait repose-toi un peu après rattaque
dans 10 minutes mais là c'était chaud là
je me suis retourné dans un vrai
chantier
c'était vraiment les mecs qui sont sur
les chantiers je les respecte grave si
c'est vraiment dur ce que je dis
toujours quand les gens se battent pour
les 35 heures quand on porte des sacs de
ciment 35 heures c'est déjà beaucoup
c'est grave j'ai pas pensé
c'est vrai après vous avez bossé dans
une pizzeria
et vous êtes fait arnaquer vous êtes
tout cassé je suis opéré ouais je vais
pas dire son nom
au début j'ai bossé c'est bien renseigné
au début j'ai
du bus c'était que du c'était de 10h du
matin jusqu'à 4h après il m'a dit viens
le soir un peu tout ça un peu d'argent
bon je me suis dit bon ok mais là c'est
trop noir après le soir
j'ai été je me suis dit je vais me faire
de la maïs ça va être bon après à la fin
du mois il m'a payé je vais me payer
4000 francs déjà pour l'avenir tous les
matins et je vois à la fin du truc je
suis venu le soir et tout c'était chaud
il m'a rajouté 500 francs
mais tu vas me donner mon argent ici là
sur la vie de ma mère sur me donner mon
argent
pour une chaise dans la vitrine
l'histoire de la pizzeria et alors un
jour vous entendez Nova et vous entendez
sur Nova votre copain Passi avec qui
vous étiez en 6e et vous vous dites si
lui il chante pourquoi pas moi parce que
ce qu'on faisait des on faisait des
freestyle ensemble avec passé qu'on est
du pur on est tout petit dans le bac à
l'école on faisait des frissons râpé
ensemble hein après je mets Radio Nova
j'entends pas si grave ouais pas si je
m'appelle pas si l'enculé
tu passes à la radio maintenant moi
aussi ça allait à la radio moi je vais
prendre une semaine j'ai écrit quatre
textes
après mes potes à Mika Jean Richard et
moi j'ai fini on va Radio Nova elle a
été
on a été on a été j'ai sonné je
m'appelle Stomy je voudrais monter
rappel ils m'ont raccroché
ta mère mon verre direct
juste un problème avec les rappeurs en
ce moment là c'est que vous êtes en
train de réussir vous devenez bourgeois
quoi on parle toujours de l'argent des
rappeurs toujours de l'argent des
rappeurs mais un mec un mec comme Cabrel
ou Goldman qui fait qu'ils font des
millions
avec ça la télé et tout comme ça on
parle pas sur l'argent autant le mec il
est blindé nous on est des crevards
ça se trouve on a on a tant mieux tu
vois mais de côté
viens alors on va voir maintenant
on va voir Stomy Bugsy très chic des
filantes pour Smalto
[Musique]
pas on va faire une interview moralité
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça a pas trop bougé là non
ça va pas compris
on bouche pas pendant le jingle ça c'est
formidable
Michel Leeb est-ce que vous avez déjà
piqué dans le porte-monnaie de votre
maman ouais j'ai eu deux fois ça m'a
traumatisé j'ai senti sale mais vraiment
sale
vous gagnez au loto et le billet pas à
vous vous le rendez
ça dépend c'est à qui
ça
fout est-ce que vous êtes déjà arrivé de
sortir avec la copine d'un copain non
jamais non non jamais jamais à part si
il a voulu me faire un coup c'est la
police si jamais elle a voulu essayer de
pêcher au ma meuf ah oui d'accord
vous avez des choses
c'est un commerçant se trompe en vous
rendant la monnaie vous lui dites si
c'est une petite vieille qui a une
boutique ou un truc comme ça là en
direct mais si c'est un grand truc je
vais pas faire le Guillaume attendez
vous m'avez rendu ah ça c'est un nouveau
mot ça veut dire alors ça c'est un mot
voilà c'est quoi c'est un mot que
j'entends de temps en temps ça veut dire
quoi faire le Guillaume c'est un mec je
sais pas c'est ça peut être un mec qui a
une pomme sur la tête
ça peut être un faux un faux rebelle un
mec comme ça je vais donner un exemple à
Guillaume qui rappe stylé c'est pas
parce que attends
c'est pas parce que j'habite dans le 16
et que mes parents me donne 10000 francs
par mois que j'ai pas le droit de crier
l'injustice pourquoi vous m'avez pas
laissé traîner avec des Arabes et des
Noirs c'est à cause de vous tu vois
il y a plein de trucs Guillaume ça va
loin tu vois ça va le voir ça va
Guillaume c'est les élections
est-ce que vous avez déjà fouillé dans
le sac de votre copine ouais bien plus
encore même
je suis un grand grand fouilleur un
grand fouilleur un espion je peux rester
dans le dans le placard enfermé donc moi
j'y vais je festige claque la porte je
reste dans le placard enfin mais je mets
un cheval sur moi je reste comme ça et
j'écoute les conversions je peux rester
une journée en dessous un lit en train
d'écouter là je suis un grand
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
NES de la grosse émission chaque jour
des millions de personnes sont victimes
de la violence demain ce sera peut-être
vous moi Sami silver j'ai été élevé en
Australie par les moins de Tibétains
aujourd'hui je suis cheten dan de
vomissieux le vomissieux m'a appris une
chose importante chaque objet qui vous
entoure peut devenir une arme redoutable
aujourd'hui le téléphone portable
simulation Fabien il y aura mon
agresseur
je marche dans la rue
[Musique]
je suis ton frère donc je simule
j'ai remarque dans la rue
[Musique]
dès le début de la gestion vous sortez
votre téléphone portable vous tirez
l'antenne vous vous précipitez vers
votre agresseur et vous lui dites c'est
pour vous allô c'est qui vous profitez
de l'attention pour lui acheter à maki
enchaîné avec un Suzuki et enfin vous
l'achetez avec un vent qui pue
voilà simulation est terminée Fabien tu
peux te relever
[Musique]
repose-toi bien défendre avec un gant de
toilette pas
[Musique]
quand vous voulez je rappelle le titre
de votre livre mes chers amis c'est le
cas de le dire
voilà
allez c'est
et maintenant j'accueille quelqu'un
maintenant j'accueille quelqu'un qui est
aussi beaucoup
[Musique]
Christine
[Applaudissements]
de la République
alors vous dites d'ailleurs maintenant
en parlant de votre livre la [__] de
la République j'aurais bien fait de
l'appeler [__] de République ouais
c'était pas mal aussi comme tips
que j'osais pas faire encore
ce livre là
ah ça je dis pas
je vais le dire 1 million
vous êtes très mal informés
alors vous revenez ce soir et vous me
dites d'une certaine façon parce que
j'ai vu votre bouquin vous me dit
Thierry je vous ai menti ah oui je vous
ai menti hein
moi je vous croyais non mais vraiment
non mais sérieusement
dit toi Ardisson tu es vachement et avec
elle t'a fondu complètement et moi mais
il faut la comprendre la pauvre tu vois
tout ça et maintenant je m'aperçois
c'est terrible enfin pas que des
histoires d'ailleurs il y a deux trois
points qu'on verra mais dans ce livre je
dis pourquoi j'ai menti trop sympa avec
vous il y a elle qui a voulu me faire un
procès parce que j'avais dit
tout à l'heure avec Pierre Botton il
vous a bien étrié sur Europe 1 l'autre
matin là pourquoi pour votre avis il a
été si méchant avec vous je pense qu'il
y a certaines je sais pas je crois qu'il
y a beaucoup de choses importantes et
des vérités qui font mal quelquefois et
puis il y en a qui qui supporte pas et
puis et puis on voudrait que j'arrête de
parler et d'écrire
alors les médias ont commencé par
accueillir votre livre je dirais un peu
du bout des lèvres un peu avec des
pincettes et dans Le Nouvel Observateur
Eri routier qui est un très très bon
journaliste qui connaît en plus
l'affaire Elf puisqu'il a écrit forage
en eau profonde
avec Valérie lecable
Eric routier dit et si Madame deviez-je
en cours avait cessé de mentir et il
donne un certain nombre de d'arguments
prouvant d'une certaine façon alors là
vous avez pas mal refaire le coup ne
regardez pas comme ça les interdit de me
regarder parce que je vais encore
craquer et puis à chaque fois je après
je me fais engueuler on me dit Thierry
tu as été trop sympa avec elle pourquoi
vous avez remis ça avec du mal
parce que maintenant j'ai dit toute la
vérité mais vous savez ça fait un moment
que je la dis on l'oublie ça fait quand
même depuis le printemps dernier que
j'ai dit la vérité
c'est un peu comme le livre de Pierre
Botton il est sorti depuis une semaine
il y a pas eu de plainte
personne vous attaquait en disant c'est
pas vrai parce que c'est la preuve que
je monte pas parce que si je cite pas
mal de gens là dedans et si vraiment et
des détails des gens et c'est vraiment
je mentais je pense que depuis une
semaine il y a plein de gens qui se
remonter au créneau disons allemands
c'est pas vrai pour l'instant c'est le
silence c'est plutôt bien ça crédite me
dire
vous connaissez l'affaire
je vais vous faire un résumé de la faire
en question ça permettait comme ça nos
amis téléspectateurs
l'histoire échange avec debout et toi
après je sais plus j'ai décroché moi
je devienne chasseur exactement alors je
répète je rappelle l'affaire pour ceux
qui l'ont oublié dans Thomson veut
vendre de l'armement à Taïwan c'est à
dire exformues Chine nationaliste si
frégate pour se protéger de la Chine
communiste de Pékin voilà Taïwan c'est
une toute petite île donc ils ont besoin
d'avoir des armes jusque là c'est clair
ouais j'ai compris
mais à cause du gouvernement français du
gouvernement français dit non on va pas
vendre d'armes à Taïwan puisque nous on
est amis avec la Chine communiste avec
la grande Chine voilà
se disent on va utiliser le réseau Elf
qui est parce que elle je suis encore
condamné mais c'est pas seulement de
l'essence il y a aussi des réseaux
et les Verts
et alors votre patron donc enfin votre
ami à l'époque Alfred cervenne qui était
le numéro 2 patrons et amis numéro 2 de
elfe à l'époque dirigée par Loïc Le
Floch Prigent bah il vous demande
d'influencer
Roland Dumas jusque là c'est clair
influencé ça veut dire quoi
c'est pas tout à fait l'histoire mais
c'est pas influencé en tout cas j'essaye
d'employer des mots voilà
étrangères c'était votre amant et vous
êtes chargé de l'influencer pour que le
gouvernement français accepte qu'on
vende des frégates à Taïwan même si
c'est pas exactement ça c'est terrible
parce que on dit c'était mon amant à
l'époque c'était ma vie privée qui
aurait jamais dû se savoir il y avait
mon travail et ma vie privée c'est vrai
que le malheur pour moi c'est que toutes
ces mélangé et que ça a mal fini voilà
bien alors pour faire sauter le véto du
gouvernement français on vous demande
d'influencer Roland Dumas on vous
promettant des valises de dollars il y a
beaucoup d'argent assez arrivé combien
vous aviez 0,5 % de la commission sirène
avait 0,5 ça faisait combien pour vous
45 millions
45 millions c'est à dire 45 millions
j'ai eu 45 millions 45 millions mon
garçon
donc vous passez du temps et si
d'influencer Roland Dumas voilà
et alors vous employez les arguments
d'enfer à un moment vous lui dites
il y a des ouvriers à Lorient qui
attendent leur lettre de licenciement
qui travaille chez Thomson
était en sur le point de fermer
si on peut dire voilà
et Roland Dumas donc finit par dire oui
donc la vente a lieu et après c'est plus
compliqué je crois là-dedans on est là
jusqu'à
nos amis d'abord sur le plateau et
ensuite pour tes spectateurs de
d'expliquer un peu l'histoire donc
effectivement vous êtes censé toucher
une commission donc de 45 millions de
francs sur mon travail
je peux prendre la suite
c'est que ce réseau à elle fait signer
un contrat avec Thomson s'entend bien
sur sur ce travail donc avec le réseau
elle qui devait être payé puis le
contrat se fait et là
on apprend que les commissions sont
versées parce que vous savez que les
commissions c'est légal le ministère du
Budget
créditentson ne veut plus payer ce
réseau elle qui est le seul qui a
travaillé et que par contre il invente
chinois on sait pas d'où il sort qui a
quand même touché sur les deux contrats
parce qu'il y avait les frégates d'abord
et il y avait les mirages de mille et
les missilatra Mika
et là on apprend qu'il y a 5 milliards
et demi de commissions qui ont été qui
sont revenus
pour faire les commissions
de commissions effectivement c'est
beaucoup d'argent
qui sont revenus et on sait on sait pas
où alors le réseau Elf a porté c'est
fâché on portait plainte donc ils sont
allés en Italie
de Genève ou le réseau Elf a gagné et
puis un jour il y a une huissier qui est
allé à la tour Thompson en disant ben
maintenant il faut payer le réseau comme
ils avaient déjà payé 5 milliards et
demi
le réseau elles sont des escrocs et je
me suis retrouvé avec Fleury-Mérogis
voilà l'histoire voilà
[Musique]
mais ce soir c'est une émission comme ça
c'est un peu chaud
par le sexe le monde ça se trouve j'ai
pas pris de la Napoléon sa femme elle
lui a dit dans ce pays-là on va voir si
tu es un homme ou l'autre tout le monde
qui contrôle le monde bien sûr c'est le
morceau de votre CD Estonie qui mène
c'est grave quoi et je vais le lire
non tu vois comment ça se passe alors
maintenant on a Marie c'est vrai que mon
propos c'est vrai Thierry que je vous ai
menti et j'espère que vous me
pardonnerez mais je vous ai menti je le
dis dans le début du livre j'ai mon
petit et je mentais donc encore quand je
suis venu sur ce plateau il y a non pour
trois raisons la première
c'est que à l'époque j'avais une défense
qui me disait on m'a même dit que
j'étais un cahier des films noirs
américains pareil parce que j'avais rien
dit pendant 5 mois et demi que c'est
très rare parce que tous les hommes
n'ont fait à faire je peux dire que il
reste pas 5 mois et demi sans ça
d'encourage en eau profond deuxième
raison donc raison on m'avait dit faut
rien dire il faut la fermer et en plus
j'ai mis un homme que je protégeais bon
donc c'est vrai que j'ai rien dit
deuxième raison j'avais gardé l'argent
que j'ai gagné sur ces frégates je l'ai
je l'ai mis à disposition de la justice
je l'ai donné à l'époque
pourquoi et ben pour qu'aujourd'hui pour
pour que ma vérité soit entendue
aujourd'hui ma vérité à nouveau elle me
coûte 26 millions cet argent je compte
le récupérer parce que ça prouvera que
j'ai pas volé et que j'ai fait mon
travail et se trouve une blague
pour ça
on va récupérer l'argent
c'est qu'un époque au Roland Dumas
croyait que Christine allait toucher
pognon il a voulu l'épouser donc ça tu
vois la police
l'argent je l'ai la deuxième raison pour
laquelle
vous vous connaissez le bouquin mais les
gens ne connaissent pas l'argent vous me
disiez à moi il y a un an vous l'avez
dit à tout le monde d'ailleurs que vous
l'aviez remis à un homme dans l'hôtel à
l'hôtel du Rhône à Genève bon en fait
vous l'avez gardé parce que vous et je
ne l'avais pas dit elle a justice donc
c'est l'une des raisons
je me souviens de vous dire
[Musique]
cette question quand même l'argent et
vous l'aviez Serge est-ce qu'on peut là
je crois que je vais être obligé de vous
poser Christine de vierge en cours la
question qui tue
Serge est-ce que je peux avoir la
lumière de la question qui tue s'il vous
plaît
ça me rappelle les bons souvenirs
alors regardez-moi Christine
alors le pognon là il est où sérieux
alors aujourd'hui il est dans une banque
en Suisse gardée par la justice suisse
je le jure
ce qu'il faut faire à la télé pour
obtenir des aveux c'est terrible c'est
terrible bien alors Roland Dumas
alors Roland Dumas donc à l'époque
épargné quand vous étiez en prison vous
avez pas balancé c'est ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure tout le monde a
parlé sur vous et rien dit pendant 5 ans
une femme une femme amoureuse les femmes
on est solide quand on aime on aime mais
pourquoi alors vous avez pas parler à
l'époque et alors c'est son indifférence
pendant votre incarcération qui vous a
poussé à vous a poussé aujourd'hui vous
le balancez du mal mais je le balance
pas je protège plus je suis allée en
prison et puis là il y a plus de
nouvelles mais mes enfants qu'ils
voyaient souvent qu'il voyait tout est
tout le temps de fois trois fois par
semaine on l'a plus revu plus jamais ma
mère qui le voyait souvent dans ma
campagne dans la plus revue plus de
nouvelles plus rien du tout et puis vous
vous souvenez qu'il a commencé à dire
que j'étais une femme parmi tant
d'autres vu que j'étais mythomane et
puis
[Musique]
14 millions et alors vous dites que
c'est elle c'est elle qui l'a donné cet
appartement à Dumas pour le d'avoir aidé
à nommer Loïc Le Floch Prigent à la tête
de elfe et moi j'étais responsable
économique de cet appartement
le mec il lui file un appartement pour
un phénomène patron
[Musique]
je pense que tout ça ça n'est pas vous
savez ce que je pense sont pas des cas
isolés on a mis la pleine lumière sur
moi parce que d'abord je suis une femme
prise en ce milieu comme ça il y en a
pas beaucoup et vous savez pourquoi
parce qu'on a trouvé une femme qu'on a
voulu prendre au lendemain et
aujourd'hui si vous regardez bien on
parle de 5000h30 de commissions sur ce
marché de Taïwan on a fait beaucoup de
bruit autour de elle qui elfe il y a pas
d'affaires elfe c'est faire le procès
des institutions de la 5ème si on fait
le procès de El c'est faire le procès de
l'Etat on peut pas on va arrêter non
mais ça va il est plus là bon et puis et
puis ça c'est réduit en pot de chagrin
jusqu'à Christine de vigencourt au
lendemain des statuettes et des
chaussures attendez je veux bien camper
pour ça et on va aller au procès c'est
normal mais moi je veux aussi qu'on
cherche ou sans passer les 5 meilleurs
et demi de commission c'est clair je dis
à nos amis
ma mère aussi
tu te rends compte là vous comprenez
pourquoi ça me donne envie de me battre
aussi vous comprenez moi j'ai pas envie
d'être le petit fusible qui va là depuis
2 ans et demi maintenant vous voulez que
je vous dise là maintenant c'est vrai
que j'en ai jusque là de que tout le
monde se met bien en avant pour
occulter les vrais maintenant
alors ça ça doit se juger aussi mais le
reste aussi il faut le chercher et ça
fait 10 ans que cette affaire existe et
que personne n'a ouvert le dossier
aujourd'hui la justice n'a pas bougé
alors maintenant on va la faire bouger
alors on va terminer on va on va parler
de votre émission veine qui était votre
patron alors aujourd'hui vous dites un
peu comme d'autres elvis est vivant vous
dites sirène est vivant vous en êtes sûr
qu'il est vivant parce qu'elle vise on
n'est pas sûr on me donne de ses
nouvelles je sais qu'il vit
d'un fax
oui l'authentifie votre livre mais il
est pas authentifié
j'avais dit chez le juge au printemps
dernier et détenteurs de de choses qui
pourraient faire sauter 20 fois la
République française donc là où il est
vaut mieux qu'il reste parce que s'il
revient ici parler
on le mettra en prison et à mon avis on
le suiciderait vite et de si commencer à
parler c'est vrai que c'est ennuyeux il
y a quand même un petit peu la
République pour faire sauter le voilà
il est pas là le mec il est planqué aux
Philippines vous avez peur de la mort
c'est un contrat sur vous quand même
pour vous alors vous savez moi je suis
sortie de ah oui je suis sortie de
Fleury d'abord vous savez quand on sort
de prison
quand on sort de prison déjà je veux
dire qu'on est bien
blindé alors j'ai été menacée quand j'ai
commencé en janvier au moment où je
venais d'ailleurs chez vous où je
commençais à dire les partis politiques
souvenez et là j'ai eu des menaces
sérieux oui vous étiez là et là j'ai eu
des menaces sérieuses
on m'envoyait des émissaires pour me
faire passer des petits messages comme
mon combat était perdu d'avance il
faudrait mieux que j'arrête des choses
comme ça intimidation intimidation et il
y a eu un contrat alors un vrai contrat
mais sur moi en juin dernier au moment
où est sorti le roman où je commençais à
balancer les clés que peu de gens ont vu
mais qui annonçait ça et qui ont que
simplement des initiés ont remarqué mais
pas le pas le public et et
là et j'ai eu un contrat sur moi mais je
vais vous dire ça m'a pas empêché de
continuer à faire ce que j'avais fait et
que j'aime bien arriver à m'avoir plus
rien avec nous c'est je fais ce que vous
voulez
mais si je dois laisser ma place
en prison Bruno Masure
bonsoir alors je vais vous dire un truc
je suis allé trois fois à Fleury-Mérogis
pour animer une émission de radio parce
qu'ils ont une radio formidable là-bas
de télévision qui n'est pas dans le
bouquin de Pierre Botton voilà comment
ça va vous vous sentez un livre que
vachement sympa qui s'appelle chérie
pense à changer de millénaire j'aurais
dû vous dire en vous présentant je l'ai
marqué sur ma fiche j'ai fait une
connerie de pas le dire
voici Bruno Masure l'homme 5 7 Nord
[Applaudissements]
je manque à tous mes devoirs
j'écris des compliments et je les fais
pas ça c'est tout moi bien alors Bruno
Masure donc France de Vivement dimanche
prochain avec Michel Drucker gélules et
Miller là je fais tout ce que vous
faites dans la semaine prochaine
alors vous êtes donc sur France 2 vous
êtes sur France Inter rien à voir ça
s'appelle c'est de 11h à 12h45 avec
Laurence Boccolini que le service public
que du service public au début vous
étiré d'accès
oui non puis j'étais mieux moi j'aime
bien être libre de mes mouvements elle
est mariée
au début puis maintenant non Ruquier
vous manque un peu c'est un peu orphelin
de mon ami Laurent que je salue ici je
suis bien France Inter mais c'est vrai
non mais j'ai une histoire avec Ruquier
et tout et je suis un homme de fidélité
donc voilà d'accord
vous êtes restés vous êtes assez honnête
vous dites je suis resté sur France
Inter parce que j'avais un engagement
moral vis-à-vis de
j'ai toujours pas de contrat mais
vous vous faites votre VSD toutes les
semaines le débloque note dans VSD voilà
bon alors on va faire la promo de votre
livre
alors
tu fais n'importe quoi
elle me dit à mesure montre son lit bah
oui mais masure va lire même des blagues
oh non je préfère
à la télé on dirait qu'il n'a jamais
cicatrie on le fait alors c'est ça
Catherine que tu veux oui 3 mois de
viagra 100 000 utilisateurs et 10 morts
et encore le lien entre ces décès et le
médicament n'est pas clairement établi
et quand bien même ça fait 90
9990 hommes heureux et 10 raides pour
l'éternité
avec Gildas aussi justice justice
Bernard Tapie ne retournera pas en
prison il bénéficie de la compression
des pennes à Téhéran 4 marchands de
tapis malhonnêtes ont été condamnés à
mort le même jour c'est pour ça que
c'est que cette forêt pétroleuse c'est
de la même page Françoise Sagan dans le
collimateur des juges Elf lui a demandé
moyennant commission de jouer les
mataris auprès de François Mitterrand
pour la conclusion d'un accord de forage
en août d'équistant Sagan pompe à
financer elfe Bonjour tristesse
vous avez vu l’allusion là
je dis que j'aurais bien vu faire la
roue de la fortune sur TF1
mais non parce que c'est le journal de
l'année 99 et c'est vrai que le
feuilleton c'est un petit peu arrêté au
début de l'année
[Musique]
tout va bien
les feux de l'amour
à la présidence de France Télévisions
Xavier Guillou Beauchant critique
vertement le comportement d'Hervé
Bourges préfet en détachement gouyou
ira-t-il mettre le feu à la période du
CSA l'affaire est suivie de près par les
concurrents de TF1 les propriétés de
chez Francis Bouygues
et voilà
alors
Bruno Masure on se concentre un peu
Christine
vous êtes d'après les sondages
l'animateur de télévision préférée des
français c'était il y a 10 ans
toujours le cas qui vous croyez
5 7 d'or et moi je me suis dit comment
ça se fait que vous ayez pas à 20h30
à la télévision toutes les semaines
et j'ai regardé pourquoi j'ai regardé
votre cas non mais je plaisante pas j'ai
regardé votre carrière et je me suis dit
que vous avez une philosophie un peu
beauf mais pas beau
du genre à quoi bon par exemple on vous
parle de Drucker vous dites c'est bien
d'être chez Drucker c'est la télé sans y
être ça ne suffit
c'est le programme minimum
espèce de alors vous êtes un peu comme
ça ça me suffit vous êtes un peu non oui
non c'est vrai le côté mais c'est un
milieu carnivore bon il y a des
émissions sympas ici ou là mais en
général c'est j'ai l'impression oui
c'est une piscine pleine de Piranha et
moi j'ai pas vraiment envie de plonger
dans la piscine parce que je trouve que
on est mieux sur la chaise longue au
bord de la piscine
en 80 je vous donne un exemple en 80
vous êtes à TF1 le président de TF1
s'appelle bouteille et il vous propose
d'être chef du service politique vous
dites non c'est fou j'avais 34 ans non
mais c'est vrai mais donc il m'a
regarder quand j'ai dit non complètement
il a dit ce mec est pas normal et il m'a
dit les trains méfiez-vous les trains de
repassent pas je dis bah je préfère
rester sur le quai mais bon voilà en 87
vous présenter le journal sur TF1 on dit
à Poivre d'Arvor tu vas présenter la
semaine et vous on vous met le week-end
au lieu de gueuler qu'est-ce que vous
dites oh il y a pas de journal et
d'autre part
en même temps bon là en même temps c'est
vrai surtout que le dimanche c'est le
jour du Seigneur donc non c'est fou quoi
ouais après d'abord vous l'aimez pas
tellement vous dites le seul point
commun qu'on a c'est d'avoir 50 ans et
d'avoir fait le 20 heures et dans
l'affaire Botton justement
vous dites que à l'étranger tout le
monde aurait démissionné après un coup
comme celui qui est arrivé non mais
c'est pas mon jugement de nos confrères
tous les correspondants étrangers à
Paris disent mais c'est fou parce que
chez nous ça ne se serait jamais passé
comme ça mais bon je porte pas de
jugement je constate simplement 10 ans
après donc là j'ai dit 87 vous faites le
journal vous faites le journal du
week-end 10 ans après en 97 je dirais de
France 2
vous êtes viré de France 2 en 97 bien
sûr pas un mot de PPDA alors que vous
l'avez envoyé un petit mot pour ces 50
ans bon enfin bon et alors vous plaignez
pas vous dites à la Saint Léger je
prends congé
d'abord
il y a un vrai il faut pas se servir de
l'antenne pour régler ses problèmes on a
la chance de pouvoir s'exprimer ailleurs
si on a des états d'âme donc il faut pas
vous auriez pu appeler Jospin c'est
votre copain depuis 20 ans je sais pas
vous auriez pu l'appeler en lui disant
je voulais pas le Lionel ils sont en
train de me mettre dehors non parce
qu'entre gouyoubochant et vous j'espère
vous mais c'est formidable justement que
j'étais viré sous la gauche ouais je
trouve c'est vrai c'est bien quelque
part c'est de l'orgueil ou de la candeur
c'est les deux les deux l'orgueil
surtout quand vous avez eu l'essai
dehors le cinquième c'est dehors après
avoir été viré vous dites je vais pas
dire merci parce que j'ai déjà été
remercié
non mais c'est génial
c'est génial
alors par exemple TF1 vous faites une
émission qui s'appelle c'est pour demain
bon c'est pas un gros succès vous dites
j'avais cru le discours d'Étienne
concernant la quête de sang
ça c'est pas de l'orgueil ou de la
candeur c'est de la naïveté ça un peu
ouais non mais c'est vrai je pensais que
une chaîne comme TF1 qui a fait un
milliard de bénéfices l'an dernier
pouvait se permettre une fois par mois
d'avoir une émission un petit peu haut
de gamme où il y a pas des jeux débiles
un public débile qui applaudit à
n'importe quel connerie et bon je me
suis trompé quoi
des Enfants de la télé par exemple mais
vous n'êtes pas les la proposer un mec
il a fait les milliardaire le mec voilà
non
c'est Bruno Masure parce que j'essaye de
faire là et c'est votre portrait avec ce
que ça à la fois de aussi de charmant de
touchant et de net quoi
je m'excuse auprès des Guillaume qui ne
sont pas les Guillaume parce qu'il y a
aussi des Guillaume qui sont pas des
Guillaume voilà c'est ça Guillaume c'est
juste un truc c'est une philosophie je
vais t'appeler Guillaume et tu as tu
imagines le mec qui s'appelle Guillaume
et qui est un Guillaume et Guillaume
Durand Guillaume Durand
Guillaume durant ou pas
la télé c'est en fait finalement je me
rends compte vite on s'embrasse sur la
bouche on se soignant dans le dos c'est
un univers carnivore qu'on venait de le
dire et c'est pas votre truc quoi un peu
non mais moi je jette pas le bébé avec
l'eau du bain il y a des il y a des
émissions formidables mais globalement
je trouve que c'est un milieu moi je
l'ai vécu je suis un vieux de la vieille
et je suis arrivé il y avait je suis
arrivé il y avait un côté encore un peu
ludique un peu maintenant c'est une
industrie et donc quand on propose une
émission On demande pas du tout est-ce
que ça va intéresser les gens on dit
combien ça coûte combien ça rapporte
mais vous rêvez d'une vie de chat
l'autre jour je disais dans un journal
vous disiez je veux dormir manger et te
caresser beaucoup caresser
de ce côté-là non parce que vous êtes
resté puceau jusqu'à 22 ans oui mais oui
vous êtes rattrapé hein
mais on peut être puceau en ayant
ah oui en ayant euro
ouais
il est en train de nous expliquer mais
je l'ai rencontré il avait 13 ans
[Rires]
voilà les couples sont faits ce soir les
couples se forment d'autant plus que
vous ne cachez pas votre bisexualité
donc voilà vous avez dit à un moment
d'ailleurs vous étiez viviez avec une
fille qui s'applique Cathy vous avez une
philosophie de couple moderne
un coup par-ci par là c'est pas un
problème de fidélité mais aujourd'hui
elle est partie quand même non ah bon
d'accord donc finalement ça marche votre
truc bien vous restez avec nous pour le
blind test alors maintenant on va faire
le blind test alors attention
[Musique]
alors c'est un blind test qui vous est
un petit peu dédié Christine devais-je
en cours
c'est un blind test argent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut reconnaître le titre et le
chanteur ou le groupe le plus rapidement
à la première note donc Cécile siméone a
dit mener à bas elle a gagné un point
[Musique]
si j'étais riche avec Rita Mitsouko
laisse tourner Didier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
très bien bravo ça fait un point pour
vous un point chacun on continue avec le
morceau numéro 3 c'est très facile
d'accord non mais je suis voilà c'est
normal attention au prochain morceau
Didier téléphone
argent trop cher bravo
vous êtes prêts Didier
directement
on voit bien regarde
[Musique]
personne n'aime personne
comment il s'appelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez on y va
du tronc
mené par les Kings
a été repris par les
on continue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
titre
2000 Tommy Bugsy a trouvé que je te
donne un summer chez Renault
même le clip
Jean-Michel Jarreau oxygène
[Musique]
ah oui
c'est chaud là
[Musique]
c'est incroyable regarder la caméra
monsieur vous êtes devenu une star ce
soir non
mais qui joue avec un curé dans un
patronage à Oran l'hémicile que j'ai
salué ici je fais comme ça
c'était dur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ne fait pas le bonheur
l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur par
Denis elle y est dedans
le nom du groupe Joe les Butagaz elle a
pas une autre là
[Musique]
que vous connaissiez l'histoire
c'est les Parisiennes
l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur par les
Parisiennes avec Dany Saval qui est
devenu depuis madame récré
pour masure 3 pour k et Olivier
alors je vais lui mettre ça je vais
venir quel est le groupe qui chante pour
vous départager
on ne souffle pas oui c'est plus tard
[Applaudissements]
s'ils ont gagné Christine comment ils
vont faire puisqu'ils sont deux
justement
vous avez pas changé d'avis maintenant
c'est ce qu'on avait dit avant
l'émission
bien maintenant on va rebaisser la
lumière
[Musique]
maintenant on va faire le jeu de la
vérité le vrai jeu de la vraie vérité
donc chacun peut poser à qui il veut la
question qu'il veut stomie
avec un jeune de 20 ans
et depuis Fleury Merogis j'ai pas eu
trop eu le temps de penser à ça mais
pourquoi pas
répondu
[Applaudissements]
le principe du jeu c'est de répondre
honnêtement bien sûr
non mais l'argent là Cécile
[Rires]
parce que dans le sport il y a toujours
une image straight hétéro machin le
sport école machin alors justement
parce que notamment dans judo est-ce que
il y a des homos
et plusieurs et ce qui se cache ou
est-ce que c'est considéré comme normal
chez les filles oui je suis beaucoup
garçon
enfin je suis pas au courant
mais c'est les garçons
[Applaudissements]
donc ça va t'inquiète pas même si je
dors mais chez les garçons non mais chez
les filles oui beaucoup
et qu'est-ce qui te permet d'être aussi
affirmatif pour les filles en disant je
sais pas chez les garçons
que bon les mecs peut-être même s'ils le
font s'en vendent pas parce qu'ils vont
se faire massacrer encore plus sur ta
famille
mais à mon avis il a répondu honnêtement
merci Jamel question
il a un côté très charmeur très tout ça
savoir c'est un truc très simple si tu
es fidèle quand tu es avec quelqu'un
même si c'est dur pendant longtemps
j'étais pas j'ai pas été fidèle depuis
ces deux dernières années ouais je suis
très très fidèle je me concentre je me
prive
de me concentrer sur mon travail sur la
musique et l'amour rien que ça qui
m'intéresse
même si c'est dur parce qu'il y a
tellement de jolies filles de mon
tentation dans ce monde là mais j'essaye
ouais ouais j'essaye j'y arrive c'est
bien à fond
une question à poser quatre
Jamel
est-ce qu'il y a certains judoka votre
sage aujourd'hui
quand même j'ai ça je lui dirai est-ce
qu'il y a des judoka qui arrive à s'auto
sucer
[Rires]
je pose la question c'est le jeu de la
réalité jamais
c'est du genre tu lui mets une balle
dans la tête il mord pas lui hein ne
regardez pas donc il y a aussi des
autosexuels
c'est le vrai jeu de la vraie vérité
là je sais pas comment les trouver un
truc qui
au fond là je les connais pas
une question pour nous
Commission en même temps
[Applaudissements]
je vous montre un truc formidable avant
de terminer je vais montrer un truc
c'est lui quelqu'un l'a vu moi qui était
énorme vous connaissez pas ça Christine
[Musique]
visage du 18 janvier c'est
extraordinaire vraiment hein
alors Jamel Bourras combat vers la
lumière chez Stock merci
[Applaudissements]
combat vers la lumière Pierre Botton qui
nous a quitté mes chers amis
Bruno Masure chérie pense à changer de
millénaire
que des livres que des livres
opération bravo
je t'ai mis trop jeune pour mourir avec
le fameux
mets ta tête dedans
c'est un grand morceau un très très
grand morceau
l'extraterrestre en salle
[Applaudissements]
et Kad et Olivier la grosse émission
voilà
tous les soirs tous les soirs à 19h sur
Comédie je suis au Canal Satellite voilà
c'était tout le monde en parle à la
semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu